ladies and gentleman the oscar-nominated
stars of love story out of a broad and
Ryan O'Neal
love-story was guided by tonight's
recipient of the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award
our director Arthur Hiller now many of
you outside the industry recognized
Arthur from his appearances on the Oscar
telecast when he was president of the
Academy but those of us inside the
industry recognized Arthur as a major
supporter of so many charities and
committees civil rights groups and
educational institutions that we wonder
how he ever found time to direct movies
like love story the in-laws the
Americanization of Emily Hospital Silver
Streak and making love and in addition
to lending his name and his wallet to at
last count 45 different groups Arthur
has taken the sort of individual action
that makes a difference in 1956 he cast
a black actor as a medical doctor on a
network television show the script had
not specified the doctors race later he
cast a wheelchair-bound actor as a
security guard also not in the script
and in the 70s Arthur and his wife Gwen
smuggled books and clothing into what
was then the Soviet Union to bring help
to the refuseniks who had been stripped
of their jobs and many of their rights
when they applied for visas to leave the
country as president of the Directors
Guild of America
Arthur helped organize committees for
the women's rights and minority rights
and created a directing program for
minorities his love story is a love of
mankind and the courage to put that love
to work for all of us for these reasons
and enough others to fill a whole three
hour show of his own were absolutely
overjoyed to present the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award to our director
Arthur Hiller
thank you mama thank you papa
it feels humbling to receive a
humanitarian award for doing what my
parents brought me up to do
I had an unbelievably caring mother and
father who lived their lives with the
moral values of love and compassion of
respect and responsibility of human
dignity and standing up for what's right
even though they had a hard time earning
a living they helped the poor and the
hungry and they also helped others who
needed the support of a friend or
someone to stand up for for their rights
they felt all other people as individual
human beings and judged them by their
actions not by their color or their race
or their religion I
I wish I could say that I'm as strong as
they were in all those areas but I'm so
grateful to them for instilling these
those values into my my loving sisters
and me and I'm so grateful to my my
loving wife and our wonderful children
and my wife so supportive and Henrik and
Erica just can't be better right there
there Gwen and the kids are always
behind me and sometimes pushing me to
live up to those values
it's so embarrassing to receive an award
for for doing what you should be doing
but
but I must admit it it pleases me
gratefully and it especially honors me
to receive it from this Academy that I
respect so deeply and that has always
meant so much to me personally
Oscar welcomes Ben Kingsley Sandra
Bullock and Hugh Grant and Denzel
Washington presents a special award to
Sidney Poitier as the Academy Awards
continue on ABC
you